good morning Hank it's Tuesday what is
this weird non airport background anyway
yesterday was the five year anniversary
of the signing of the Affordable Care
Act widely known as Obamacare which made
me wonder if it's you know like worked
so here's the summary of what I found in
the United States in 2009 more of my tax
dollars went to health care than would
if I lived in Japan or the United
Kingdom or Australia and in exchange for
all of that money we did not get the
universal health care that people in all
of those countries enjoy five years
later in 2014 we spent about the same
percentage of our GDP on health care and
we still don't have universal health
care but we do have less onion aversive
care by the way I'm gonna oversimplify
here a lot for better information you
should check out healthcare triage so
here's how it worked in the housey on
pre Obama care days of 2009 the
government provided health insurance to
elderly people through Medicare and also
to some poor people through Medicaid
many other people got insurance through
their jobs are paid for it themselves
but this still left a lot of people out
like there were 44 million people
without insurance this was obviously a
problem for those 44 million people but
it was also a problem for the rest of us
because we did have a kind of universal
health care in the United States
like when uninsured people got sick and
went to the hospital they did receive
care and if later they couldn't pay for
that care those costs would be absorbed
either by the rest of us paying higher
prices for health care or else by taxes
says the government had to subsidize
public hospitals but it wasn't really
universal health care because you can't
like go into an emergency department and
get your week supply of insulin if
you're diabetic so in the u.s. we didn't
and still don't have real universal
health care we have like if you get shot
we will try to patch that up for your
universal health care and this system
was astonishingly inefficient like we
spent more than 17% of our total gross
domestic product on health care in
countries like Canada and France and
Australia and the Netherlands they spend
less than 10 percent of their GDP on
health care and they get similar or in
many cases better health outcomes also
back in 2009 insurers could deny you
access to health care insurance if you
had a pre-existing condition
a phrase intentionally so broad that it
encompassed like everything
for instance Henry Ryan of minutephysics
was once denied insurance because he had
the pre-existing condition of tinnitus
or ringing in his
the only way to get around a
pre-existing condition Clause was if you
worked for a big company you could get
insurance through them and that of
course incentivize people to work for
big companies when they might otherwise
be doing different kinds of work like I
don't know making minutephysics videos
so the Affordable Care Act ought to make
the labor market less bananas decrease
health related bankruptcies the number
one cause of bankruptcy in the United
States and ultimately to insure those 44
million people without insurance while
at the same time over time decreasing
the amount of money we spend on health
care it was going to solve the access
problem by creating these health care
exchanges where private companies could
compete for people's business but they
couldn't discriminate based on gender or
pre-existing conditions so law also
would expand Medicaid which would get
insurance to more poor people and it
required companies with more than 50
employees to provide affordable
insurance to their employees or else pay
a gigantic penalty this would all be
paid for more than paid for hopefully by
cost control measures these ranged from
getting tougher on Medicare fraud to
incentivizing hospitals to keep elderly
patients healthy so they don't get
readmitted to the hospital there's also
a new tax on like tanning salons and an
increase in the Medicare payroll tax for
income over two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars a year but has it
worked yes insofar as things are better
than before and also no in so far as we
are nowhere close to a path to
sustainable health care spending so the
ACA was phased in slowly and the real
meat of it didn't get going until 2014
you'll recall the rollout of the health
care exchanges in late 2013 was a
complete disaster the website
healthcare.gov was plagued with glitches
and really just didn't work
admittedly buying private insurance in
the u.s. before the Obamacare exchanges
was arguably even worse than
healthcare.gov but it was just terrible
I remember trying to sign up in those
early months and it was truly awful what
has not been widely reported is that now
it's really easy in general the
exchanges now work very well and more
than 12 million Americans including me
have signed up for insurance through
them insurance premiums are going up on
average more slowly than they did before
the exchanges and more insurers are
participating which means there will be
more competition in the market plus the
law is costing less than expected
because fewer employers then expect it
have dropped people off their insurer
and it doesn't seem to be negatively
affecting the job market it certainly
led to more freedom in the labor market
for instance Sarah green could leave her
insurance providing museum job to start
an art show with PBS Digital and
certainly for people who can get
insurance now who couldn't before either
because of pre-existing conditions or
because they couldn't afford it without
the government subsidies the ACA is a
really big deal and none of the collapse
of the health care system or death panel
predictions have come to pass instead
uninsurance rates in the US have dropped
dramatically and early signs indicate
that at least in some sectors the law is
improving health by the way sources for
all this stuff in the doobly-doo on the
other hand many millions of people still
don't have insurance and under insurance
where people technically have insurance
but still end up with medical bills they
can't afford is a huge problem and while
the growth of our health care costs has
slowed we still spend over 17% of our
GDP on health care most other developed
countries spend far less than that and
still have citizens who live longer and
healthier lives than Americans and
before you say that's because Americans
eat or drink or smoke or whatever more
than British people know that's simply
not true have you ever met an actual
British person I don't mean like Jack or
Finn or Charlie I mean a real one so
yeah if nothing changes health care
costs are still going to crush us in the
long run because the thing about the ACA
is that it's not particularly radical
like the 12 million people who've gotten
insurance through the exchanges that's
less than 4% of Americans the vast
majority of people very little has
changed and that means that the
underlying problems haven't really
changed we spend way too much on health
care and we get too little in return to
take that seriously would require
radical change government interventions
like price controls for instance or a
single-payer health care system or a
truly free market system where if you
show up to the hospital with a gunshot
wound and you can't pay for treatment
you don't get treatment so in the old
system definitely wasn't working the ACA
is working insofar as its job is to get
health insurance to people who don't
have it without disturbing the health
insurance ecosystem for most people but
the ACA didn't really replace an
existing system so much as it grew on
top of it now the fact that so many
insurers are bringing more plans to the
exchanges indicates that probably the
ACA will continue to work on
as the Supreme Court eviscerates it in a
few months but the ACA has not and will
not solve the long-term health care
spending challenge that we face
neither of course would repealing the
law if anything the healthcare spending
problem was worse before Obamacare
rather than the endless discussions of
repeal or defend we should be frank
about the choices before us as
healthcare economists and healthcare
triage host Aaron Carroll told me
trade-offs are messy you can get reform
more easily and more cleanly but not
necessarily while preserving the private
market you can make health care cheaper
but not without imposing even more
regulation you can ensure more people
and make it cost less for everyone but
not without spending more tax dollars
Hank health care policy experts across
the political spectrum seem to
acknowledge this complex reality it's
our job now to make our politicians
acknowledge it too again for more
information and lots of other videos
about health care please check out
healthcare triage hank thanks for
reminding me last week about the many
pleasures of being in a crowd I will see
you on Friday